si la jugadora de baloncesto
estadounidense regresa a casa Esto será
posible gracias a un intercambio de
prisioneros Estados Unidos ha devuelto a
Rusia a un prisionero ruso que tenía
aquí desde hace 11 años y que había sido
condenado a 16 años de prisión por
tráfico de armas el presidente
estadounidense Joe biden ha dicho que la
deportista se encuentra sana y salva
regresando ya a casa su avión aterrizará
en el aeropuerto de San Antonio en Texas
allí será sometida a un examen médico y
más tarde podrá reunirse con su familia
aunque hemos sabido que su esposa la
esposa de la deportista ya ha podido
hablar con ella Desde el despacho oval
ya ha confirmado que efectivamente se
encuentra perfectamente una gran noticia
con las navidades a la vuelta de la
esquina pero un tanto agridulce porque
Estados Unidos quería incluir en este
acuerdo otro detenido estadounidense que
se encuentra en Rusia pero Rusia no ha
aceptado se trata de un empresario de
una de un ejecutivo de una empresa de
seguridad que fue detenido el pasado 18
de diciembre del 2018 cuando acudía a
una boda en el país ruso tras ser
acusado de espionaje